on the menu is a succulent rare beef
fill it with sulfur building served with
roasted truffle new potatoes right Jack
get that pan nice and hot realize that
this is a rolls-royce cutting motif so
we've got to treat it with some respect
okay yeah mop up all that seasoning yeah
into the pan and get that really nice
and hot hello it tails what's the name
Rhodes me Liberty garlic and thyme in
now cooking with these aromatic herbs
and garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a filet of beef there's
hardly any fat on there so you sear it
quickly ends as well get said I'm gonna
put some butter in there continue frying
all those herbs now base that with the
butter know they serve some beautiful
baked potatoes with truffle and a salsa
verde in the oven 8 to 10 minutes that's
all next my super special baked new
potatoes wash and drain small new
potatoes and tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil and season with a
touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper place into an oven preheated at
180 degrees Celsius and bake for 35
minutes until crisp on the outside and
soft all the way through transfer to
your serving dish and grate over fresh
Parmesan cheese last but not least shave
gorgeous earthy black truffle slivers
onto the cheesy potatoes baked new
potatoes with a lavish twist indulgent
but couldn't be simpler to make right it
sounds a birthday and cherries it will
touch of anchovy oil in there okay after
that we have some capers garlic in with
the anchovies and the capers of you a
touch of salt why only a touch Dijon
mustard
sho vinegar give that a nice mix now
this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley I want half
of it in there
pureed touch of olive oil in there and
the rest of the mint just salt pepper
excited
and no taste was it might need to try a
tiny bit more no kissing boys now before
the kids polish up all the cells of LD I
need a distraction
and I think my B fill it will do the job
nicely look at this baby potholes up
look at that
Sears and look how juicy and tender that
is take that out and let that sit on
there a little spoon just why it's it's
Andres sauce overly as the beef cools
down as south of there they marinades
that goes the table very carefully beats
tills take it over look the baked
potatoes please this is my ultimate
special occasion dinner the tenderest
rare beef fill it with punchy cells of
LD serve with extravagant truffled new
potatoes it's always a special occasion
in our house and my wonderful mum and a
husband Jimmy turn up for dinner
[Music]
this is a definite special occasion
cheers man just slice a sandwich in half
[Music]
each